oh wait
and now
i'm here with upon us and upon the Quran
and of course you are Alfonso son how is
it working together father and son I
think since we understand each other
after 30 years living together I think
it made things in many ways easier I end
up learning more from pronounce and I
think the show the film shows him he's
just a new approach a fresh approach to
see things so so tell me a little bit
about the story the I guess the idea of
the film was to create a movie were the
experience went back to something very
primal space also was a great setting
for this movie because it's so far away
from Earth so in many ways it's
terrifying once you're up there anything
goes wrong and you're in big trouble
no now
to make this film took us four and a
half years the difficult thing here's
the integration between animation and
live-action and cg lighting the whole
thing takes place in co ji so characters
are known the floating but just rolling
and spinning improved to be impossible
to do it with good wires because you
would see the wires are very limiting
and also ah the day you can see the
strain on the actors and we try
different things will try the vomit
comet that is called is the parabolic
flight and you're limited by the size of
the plane inside so we needed to invent
our own technology we adapted those
robots that they build cars with to have
cameras and lights wire machines but
that they were pre-programmed combined
with LEDs that there was not one single
technology up because each moment
require different technology from the
moment that you watch in the movie you
read at the edge of your seat you
partake with the characters experience
it's so cool that we've seen our members
of the audience watching the film and
struggling to breathe is very immersive
that's the cool thing of the film
you